day forecast to maybe a three-day
weekend are you planning to travel this
year three-day weekends in 2021 will
look vastly similar
to last year all about safe road travels
kirsten joyce joins us live from her
home with some popular picks for
travelers hi kirsten
hi ryan we caught up with vacasa one of
the largest vacation
property management companies in the u.s
who shared some pretty interesting data
with us
turns out that occupancy at its vacation
properties increased in 2020 during the
pandemic
compared to the year prior the director
of operations for vacasa says that
highlights that people are willing to
travel within their bubble
and stay in more of a vacation type home
than that of another type of
accommodation
this year already the rental property
company is seeing similar trends to last
year with three night getaways booking
up for people who are
working remotely and folks looking to
drive to their destinations
what we're seeing actually surprisingly
with a global pandemic is
really strong demand for for cabin
and lakefront property and i think we've
seen since the pandemic started
those more remote getaways have seemed
almost a 50
increase in demand and so prices
accordingly have gone up a little bit
but what we're noticing is there's still
a lot of great deals to be had if people
plan ahead and look to
to book farther out so the top three
places in 2020 for bookings included
fire island which is just off the coast
of long island in new york
electric city in washington state it's
right near lake chelan
and lake anna in virginia now although
nevada didn't make any lists for the
three-day weekend hot spots in the
vacation rental property category
our neighbors in flagstaff arizona and
st george utah certainly did brian
i didn't eat i should say
okay kirsten thanks so much and